i'm not going to marry you guys i'm
marrying vinya
[Music]
okay this moment came way sooner than i
expected which makes me wonder
wow how much more drama do we have in
store this is only the beginning
binyam chooses to wait until the night
before he leaves to tell his sisters
he's moving to the u.s
the night before
yet somehow red wine ends up on ari's
face we'll get into what led up to his
sister wish throwing the drink
oh my goodness
i'm kind of in shock
and what she had to say to the camera
afterwards
they only have 90 days i hope they
couldn't make it
plus this is where you'll be staying at
oh my god
shatter reacts after below takes her to
his actual home where she will be living
this comes after his controversial prank
i wanted to see if scheider truly wants
me for me not for what i have were he
fooled shot into believing that they
were going to be staying in his modest
childhood home i definitely would say i
would probably do some things
differently for sure that little bit
that i said we still have arguments
based on that you'll also get a sneak
peek at the exclusive conversation i had
with shaida and bilal that honestly
changed my entire perspective on them as
a couple y'all context is everything
because that just changes the entire
conversation let's talk about it
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia oh boy
oh boy does shada and bilal start a
conversation last week
i actually want to chat about them
before we get into binyam and ariela
you know after reading some of your
opinions this week's episode and my
interview
i can admit my perspective on chad and
bilal as a couple has evolved
specifically my opinion about shaida
although she had her moments last week
you want something to eat
yeah something that i'm a clean bowl
yeah
yeah well i can order something
i know you don't want to eat you have
enough money for that
that was harsh i felt i i i regret that
during this episode
after she wakes up at bilal's childhood
home and apologizes to him for her
behavior i do want to apologize the way
i acted yesterday
yeah i should have never had an outburst
or say thanks to you that was unkind she
said something that allowed me
personally to get a better understanding
of where all of her frustration and
anger was really coming from one of my
concerns and
that i kind of overreacted was
i came here on a k1 visa
yeah i'm unable to work for a very long
time
yeah so you are my
sole provider
right
can you take care of me below i would
not have brought you
to casey
with not the intentions of me being able
to take care of you
she was afraid that she would be here in
america struggling
and i don't want to give too much away
but during my interview these two drop a
bomb that literally changes everything
when it comes to this prank test
situation
those of you who aren't really feeling
below your thoughts on him might change
a bit
they might there were some strong
opinions out there so to put things in
context
is that
uh yeah it was an element of a test but
it was really more of a prank and it was
a continuating prank that she actually
started to hear what they reveal
make sure you subscribe to entertainment
tonight's youtube channel so you can
catch the interview you can also check
it out on etonline.com
alright back to the episode bilal leaves
the house to handle some business and
shaida calls her mom who gives her some
pretty good advice
[Music]
i understand all that
but to walk into this i felt ambushed
okay
nothing
jump on and explain and bring it back
you always have a choice sweetheart
you always have a choice
that's real sometimes we forget that we
always have a choice
when bilal gets back he tells chida it's
time to go to his mother's house for
lunch
but of course he is about to take her to
his real home where she will actually be
living it's time for the big reveal
ready to meet
my mother this is nice
hello hello honey
yep
welcome to your new
home this is where you'll be staying at
oh my god
the last time
this is where you'll be staying at oh my
god
[Music]
below gives shaida a tour of the house
and look at her she is all smiles but
when he takes her to a special room that
he created just for her she breaks down
in tears
i got a little something else to show
you
oh my god
oh my god
since she created her own yoga studio
back in trinidad
bilal created a yoga studio in his home
for her
is this when i made the newspaper
[Music]
you like it
[Music]
that yoga room brought out so much
emotions it was something sentimental
for me the yoga room back home is a
studio that i was renting but this yoga
space this is actually mine
[Music]
that was sweet
since we're on shada and bilal i want to
take a look at some of your answers to
last week's question
if you had to choose between true love
that last or financial wealth that last
what would your choice be
let's take a look at sandy's answer she
said quote true love all the way i've
been married 37 years going strong we
don't have wealth but we have love
health and happiness that's all that
matters
look sandy has been married 37 years
when it comes to love
i think she's earned the right for us to
listen to her
traveling with allah says quote love
fades super quick when money issues sink
in
money is important in a marriage
especially when you want to start a
family
interesting perspective i've definitely
seen that happen
you know the older i get the more i
realize how big of a role finances play
in adult relationships
the bliss of being a child things were
so simple
adulting ain't easy even when you're
happy
last but not least kinda love forgive me
if i said your name wrong says quote i
take true love over money every time
everyone just needs to be real with each
other the games are not necessary and a
waste of time
true
nowadays it literally feels like finding
gold when you come across someone who
can just be real with you
it's rare see that's what makes it so
sweet
i love having these conversations and
seeing all of your different
perspectives y'all are funny
smart good writers and just overall
creative
somebody asked why below doesn't flip
his childhood home since that's what he
does for a living and i was like that's
a good question
i actually ended up asking him that my
father actually helped build that house
and so he didn't want anybody touching
his house at houses or anything like
that so it's not necessarily a house
that i own so out of respect you know i
know didn't do anything to it
all right let's move on to ariella and
binyum's dramatic 90 day fiance debut my
name is ariella i'm 30 years old and i'm
from princeton new jersey
i live in ethiopia with my fiance binyam
and our son avi the last time we saw ari
and benny they were trying to pick up
the pieces to their broken relationship
on last season's 90-day fiance the other
way they went through a lot
i never could have predicted how bad the
distance would be for our relationship
ari left ethiopia and returned to new
jersey solo so that their son avi could
get surgery
and benjamin was terrified
seeing aries left he reminded my ex-wife
because before i i'm married american
woman we have son
and then when you leave he doesn't come
back
my first baby i didn't see him
now like three years and a half
i didn't never see him
[Music]
i hope you will come back
when ari got to america she had to stay
longer than expected due to the baby's
surgery
and binium stopped picking up the phone
number unavailable because his phone is
off he literally just does not pick up
the phone ari also suspected that he was
cheating on her
shut them up and listen
god knows who you are and god knows what
you've been doing and i don't even care
and i don't even want to know but after
deciding to take a getaway to kenya to
get back to the basics in their
relationship they chose to make it work
i'd like us to try to go to the us
bring back the beard fast forward to
sunday's episode binium's k-1 visa got
approved and he ahri and avi are moving
to the u.s in three days when vinnie
moves to the u.s i don't think 90 days
is enough to work out all of the issues
that benny and i have
if the old mini comes back
and he started partying going clubbing
to avoid dealing with his feelings
i don't think the relationship will
survive
and it seems like that doubt right there
it's part of the reason why binyum is so
nervous to tell his family about the big
move they know that this relationship
has been an emotion
i'm so worried for telling from my
family you know just
until still now why would you wait
because i don't want to make a mistake
for everybody and you know they'll be
happy for you somebody has to be an
optimist while ari is thinking best case
scenario when it comes to his family's
reaction
binyum comes up with this plan that
spells disaster
tonight i have to pick up my music
and second tell my friends
about i'm living after binyam tells his
friends the news they are clearly
bothered and concerned
beanie going to the us i can't really
digest it you know
i hear him in ariela argue sometimes he
comes to me and tells me some kind of
things so from the third person view
like that's not the best relationship
i've ever seen in my life is that a nice
way of saying it's toxic
so that's the part that worries me
benny goes on to explain to his friends
why he's choosing to leave
and it's mainly because he believes his
son avi is a gift from god and he
doesn't want to be far away from him
he also says if he didn't love ari which
he says he does but if he didn't he
would still move to the u.s to be with
his son
irish is going
from like
my baby he's going i don't have chase
whatever is happening i will fight
like savings this relationship
otherwise i think i would lose to my
family again binium goes on to tell his
friends that he hasn't told his family
yet
and he reveals the plan the money
uh
[Music]
which is to tell his family at the
premiere party for his music video
the party is the night before he leaves
they're so happy and then i will tell
them just
so they're not going to tell him that
that doesn't sound like a good idea good
luck
according to ari binyum loves to avoid
conflict vinnie is a serial conflict
avoider
but it's interesting that while he
thinks he's avoiding it he's actually
creating more of it
sometimes you just have to face the
beast and deal with it i honestly
feel really bad for vinnie's family and
friends that he didn't tell them that
he's moving because it was going to make
them feel like he doesn't care about
them
the night comes for binham to tell his
sisters intentions are already high when
they walk in the party
as we've seen over the years they
haven't gone along that well with ari
and apparently at this point they
haven't spoken in a while linda
yeah she don't want to touch you
damn she says she doesn't want to touch
ari because of kovid but
she's maskless at a party that sounds
like an excuse i guess to each his own
i'm so happy i didn't accept it like
people they like us even ali she likes
she's dancing
wait look at ari we have to rewind that
it's so cute after everyone enjoys the
party for a bit binium sits them down
and lets his family know that his life
is about to change forever and so are
theirs
so
[Music]
wishing mimi don't take the news well
wish questions why binium waited this
long to tell them and then they start to
put the blame on ari
[Music]
this is her fault he likes you all this
man who played him you know she always
control him she's control freak
and he always come and tell us like he's
not happy so
we're really scared that what's gonna
happen to binyam after he lived to in us
because
i don't trust her
see this is the downside to telling your
family about issues in your relationship
because when you choose to move on from
the problem it can be hard for them to
forget and let it go
which can cause more inner conflict for
you
him not telling you this has nothing to
do with me it's nothing to do with me at
all until you can tell the truth that i
never said anything to you about it and
i would never tell him not to tell his
family that would she's up on so many
levels i would never do that but you're
also our family you should tell us you
guys are my family i know but you know
sometimes
or you say something for some reason
benjamin is acting like he can't talk
right now
he started this and his mouth is closed
shut
smart man
i think he should speak up and take more
responsibility
and because he doesn't the conversation
continues to escalate i don't care like
whose fault it is but if you think you
are family you should tell us you should
tell us to right because yes that's his
life we treat you like a sister like you
don't treat me like a sister you guys
are really if that's how you treat your
sister i want nothing to do
benny is an adult and he ended up making
a stupid decision not to tell his
sisters the fact that they blamed me for
his decision
it's ridiculous okay i'm happy that i'm
not gonna see you guys anymore and you
know what i didn't marry i'm not going
to marry you guys i'm marrying vinya
wait look at ari's eyes she looks down
at that glass i wonder did she see it
coming
[Music]
uh it's crazy oh my god i've never
gotten alcohol to the right place before
that's a new experience
now out of all the times i've seen
someone get a drink thrown in their face
on reality tv
i have never heard a reaction like aries
that's a new experience
in my opinion wish is just misplacing
the hurt and anger she feels about her
brother leaving on ari she don't respect
us she don't respect him and i think
she's psycho
but you just um
no comment they only have 90 days i hope
they couldn't make it she said she hopes
they cannot make it
will they
no no zero person no
[Music]
those two do not play about their
brother
and to think that this was our first
episode with arie and binyum they came
in with a bang
or should i say splash
oh that was so corny well although they
end the night on bad turns next week
binyum's sisters joined him at the
airport to say their goodbyes got unless
you have to say sorry sorry for what i
don't want the last night's bad mood to
be last time when i seize it
already we have drama yesterday we don't
need more today it's stupid
[Music]
all right 90 day fans fam that does it
for this week make sure you stick with
e.t because we are covering it all i
will see you next time
you